now recall that the browser built a tree
like structure of the page and when I
say tree I don't literally mean this
type of tree
I just mean a branching structure
sideways triangles are an HTML element
each has an opening tag and a closing
tag
now this can simply be text like you see
here or it can be another element like
this span or this a so that we can get a
better visual understanding let's draw
the structure ourselves first we have
this div element then inside of the div
we have an h2 and ap element then inside
of this h2 we have the span element and
inside span we have some text now if we
go back to the P element inside we have
text and to a elements and then inside
of each of the a elements we have text
and now it's time for you to explore the
structure of a page on your own please
follow the link we have provided in the
instructor notes section below and open
Google's developer tools then create
your own tree like structure to describe
the page make sure to fill in the boxes
in the same order that they appear in
the tree and if the element contains
text write the word text in the box